ja genau das dass genau das der punkt
die sind heute so was von in watte
gepackt von ihren eltern die haben nicht
mehr gelernt irgendwie erst schaufeln
dann schütteln sich die hände schmutzig
zu machen das fängt ja schon damit an
müll rauszubringen oder zu hause zu
helfen das heißt es ist alles da sollen
alle studieren ja plädiere total dass du
das studium auf dieselbe ebene stellen
wie handwerk wenn ich mit konzernen
sprechen mit führungskräften sagte er
ohne master studium nehmen wir gar
keinen zum zum praktikum das heißt wir
haben immer mehr versucht hier eine
wissens elite zu schaffen ja die aber
dafür sei aber nichts machen musste um
einen guten job einstieg zu haben und
wenn sich die neuesten studien anschauen
nachgewiesen wenn der handwerker bist
dich weiter würdest du meistertitel hast
du am anfang mehr geld später hat dann
der studierte so sieben bis acht jahre
später mehr geld aber am ende haben
beide ungefähr ihre 1,3 millionen
erwirtschaftet laut statistik und ich
glaube wir müssen halt einfach eine
andere haltung wieder haben und dass wir
anpacken können und da muss ich leider
einmal der politik in die indy in die
integrierte sprechen habe gesehen im
aartal da gab es auf einmal wieder
nachbarschaftshilfe das heißt wenn eine
katastrophe da ist können wir das
irgendwann und wir stehen vor der
katastrophe dieses land gegen die wand
zu fahren wir sind nirgendwo mir gut ich
rede gerade mit einem weltmarktführer
mit ingenieuren die sagen china hat
längst das know-how übernommen wir
kriegen es noch niemals erwartet klaren
beiden champions aber die sind alle
leise wo sehen sie mal ein mittelstand
unternehmer ja der wirklich erfolgreich
in deutschland arbeitsplätze schafft der
aufsteht und was sagt der letzte ist für
mich rupp von ibm und die meisten
mittelstands unternehmer sind die die
chefin aber dafür nicht im mittelpunkt
stehen wollen und auch nicht müssen
sondern die einfach für dieses land
leiste habe ich eine frage an manchmal
sie ausgegrenzt sind weil 7 1 waren
leistung nummer 1 deutschland nicht mehr
doch neid ich voll überzeugen den
wirtschaftsjournalisten eigentlich
ausgeblendet ich habe viele unternehmen
der würth und viele wollen das auch gar
nicht viele wollen nicht ins rampenlicht
die sind aber in ihren eigenen dörfern
in eigene communitys sind die sehr stark
unterstützten fußball vereine vor ort
aber die brauchen nicht die große bühne
und sind trotzdem großartig unternehmer
weil ich mir heute morgen eine frage
gestellt ich habe ja gewusst worüber sie
heute abend rede mich ganz okay die
jugend ist voll geworden ab welchem
jahrgang sehen sie das denn als wäre es
für sie jung an welchem jahrgang sagen
sie denen ist immer gleich bei uns
wichtiger als jetzt das scheffel
manchmal muss man die generation web
chat anschauen dort bin ich komplett
dabei als auch beim 19 20 ja das bin ich
übrigens ich bin jahrgang radiosender
dollar aus waren vielleicht nein ich bin
ich würde nicht sagen dass ich eine
ausnahme wenn ich habe manchmal das
gefühl wenn man direkt die jugend so
verteufelt es gibt ja auch wirklich
fleißig in den herrscher jetzt machen
wir das schwarz-weiße schaut deswegen
hab ich das ja auch so krass geschrieben
weil über die grauen reden werde nicht
den graubereich gibt es ja immer aber
ist ja genau das was der glückler sagt
die fragen erst mal wie sind meine
arbeitszeiten kriechen den handy
griechen mac ja wir haben hofer ware
schreibtische wir sind dann meine
arbeitszeiten das sind fragen die nun
erstellt allem bin ich einmal einen
stopp in meiner altersgruppe genau
dasselbe da sind ja noch vorbilder jetzt
könnte man zurück auf haushalt blöd da
gesagt hat mir fehlt auch bei meinem
alter den 55-jährigen 50ern dadurch ganz
häufig bei meinen beratungen trainings
ja wissen sie ich hab ja nicht mehr
lange da soll ich haben sie kinder wie
fitness so für ihre kinder wenn sie
sagen dass kriege ich jetzt auch noch
hin warum aber ich bin 25 jahre dabei
wenn ich mal ausfiel gibt es so große
abfindung das habe ich auch noch und da
ist auch keine leistungsbereitschaft wir
kriegen dann darf ich ihnen erklären
warum ganz kurz ich habe die zahlen
nicht im kopf habe die haben sie
bestimmt ein großer anteil der
erwerbstätigen hängt an den öffentlichen
diensten handwerk leute die wie sie und
ich glöckler einen eigenen beruf haben
und eine eigene firma haben sind
inzwischen die minderheit über 50
prozent der leute die ein einkommen
haben mitziehen ist vom staat vom land
oder von der gemeinde und von diesen
leuten wird keine besondere leistung
verlangt haben 1,2 millionen beamte ja
ich habe vorhin gesagt haben menschen
nach der gallup studie 17 prozent die
leisten wollen 68 prozent die in der
mitte sind ja alles nach vorschrift
mit der 3 millionen selbständigen und
mittleren einkommen oder 30 millionen
die werte nur noch schaffen aber es hält
schon eine ganze weile vor das ist
nichts neues außerdem wollte ich noch
mal sagen welche der älteste bin es
bringt nicht viel über die schreckliche
jugend zu schimpfen das hat noch jede
ganz sicher aber auch schon getan
nein ich bin nur ein wort sagen wissen
sie es ist eine sie haben leider
vollkommen recht verfahren das gegen
gegen die wand ist es eine totale
bankrotterklärung und dann gibt es
seltsame
kontraproduktive ansätze zb die
verehrung für greta in diesem land nicht
dass eine junge verhaltensgestörte frau
zum idol einer ganzen gesellschaft
werden kann zeigt nur wie
verhaltensgestörte ganze mannschaft ist
ich war immer der meinung man muss
erst mal mehr leistung bringen zeigen
dass man mehr kann und dann kann man
mehr fordern aber sie hat man so die
sagen ich muss erstmal kriegen dann
mache ich auch mehr dann versuchen immer
zu erklären nein so funktioniert das
nicht wenn ich morgen kein job mehr
hätte überhaupt keinen job und nicht
wüsste was ich anfangen sollte dann
würde ich irgendwo hingehen zu einer
firma wird sagen pass mal auf ich putzte
jetzt eine woche oder zehn tage deine
bude mache ich alles putzig kostenlos
wenn ich dafür haben wenn du zufrieden
bestellt sich nach zehn tagen einen der
würde mich einstellen nach zehn tagen
will er wird zufrieden ja und nach vier
fünf wochen hätte ich dann den ersten
angestellten zweiten und dann in der
firma aufgemacht ja aber nein man will
erstmal will erst mehr bekommen und ich
mach doch nicht bevor ich nicht mehr
bekomme ich mach doch erst
wahrscheinlich was bekomme ich immer du
musst erst mal beweisen dass du das wert
ist leistung bekommen möchten dann sehen
wir aber nicht so und haben sie können
allen lagen so bestellten anlagen so ich
spreche mit einem vorstand der sag das
mal auf ich habe hier ein budget von 50
millionen für eines unserer größten
talente im förderungs pool da kann der
internet kampf in den bau muss dafür von
münchen nach berlin ziehen
31 jahre alt da sagt er mein kind ist
gerade in die schule kommen wir fühlen
uns jetzt in münchen wohl ich gehe nicht
mehr weg das heißt wir wollen auch noch
finde ich total schlimm wenn ihr kind
bleiben wenn sich wohl für einen stopp
stopp stopp stopp ich finde es schlimm
wenn jemand heute nicht mehr flexibel
ist sagt bei seiner chance die ich habe
eine eigene company aufzubauen der soll
mit seiner frau mirja nach nach berlin
ziehen aber nein jetzt habe ich mich ein
gericht
heute flexibilität man andere stadt
kennenlernen ein anderes bundesland
kennenlernen weiter auch den horizont
ich habe es ein bisschen gelesen sie war
auch in den usa ja das habe ich auch
gemacht hat mir sehr den horizont
geöffnet ich bin sowieso dafür dass
kinder zwangsrekrutiert werden sollen in
einem alter von 16 17 mein auslandsjahr
machen sollen aber in anderen familien
sonst hätte ich mega ich bin dafür dass
im studium mindestens ein praktikumsjahr
dabei ich mal ein jahr schneidern und
mal glück über die schulter schauen oder
dann in der pr pause dann sind sie auch
dafür als zwangs jahr praktikum zwangs
jahr ausland und dass man auch bereits
ein muss für jeden job auch flexibel in
die stadt in die städte zu ziehen sagt
nicht für jeden aber ich sage dass eine
gewisse flexibilität brauchen ja das ist
mir als als freiheitsliebende person
einfach einfach too much also ja
irgendwo stimmt das und wir haben da
eine entwicklung ich habe die kann man
auch gar nicht übersehen aber ich glaube
schon dass es auch gut ist wenn menschen
gucken was für sie richtig ist wenn sie
auch mal zu einem aber wir wissen ja
nicht alle berichte ja aber da wäre es
doch gut wenn wir versuchen wir als
gesellschaft doch eher zu investieren
menschen zu ermutigen genau das war auch
jörg fitness ist was will denn
eigentlich war ich glaube dass ein
mensch dann am produktivsten ist am
besten ist am kreativsten schönsten und
tollsten lösungen findet und auch am
meisten bereit ist über alle maßen viel
zu arbeiten wenn er oder sie das
richtige tut also es ist ja manchmal so
ein so sind wir wahrscheinlich alle
irgendwie stückweit aufgewachsen
derjenige der am meisten arbeit am
meisten tut er ist wie der beste mensch
aber aber dass sie mal weiter dagegen
die sagen ganz klar zu mehr glück ganz
ganz viele junge leute sagen ich möchte
auch ganz so berühmt werden wie sie oder
wir haben so viel arbeiten möchte ich
bin ich sagen soll ich auch immer wieder
vom alter weiter ich wäre auch gern so
erfolgreich wie alle so leben aber ich
will nicht zu glauben ja und das ist das
gibt sicherlich extrem ist das auch
nicht gut aber nur zu sagen dass viel
arbeiten per se ein wert ist finde ich
unterstütze wenn man nämlich in oslo ist
wenn man das richtige findet dann kann
man aber wir wirklich das richtige das
ist doch das thema heute schon die gehen
machen ja
ja das kann ja auch helfen natürlich im
jahr was nach zwölf jahren die eng
gepresst sind wenn man 17 ist ein
abiturient reden aber
auch an im ausland dann haben sie ein
praktikum im ruhrgebiet geborene letzte
von drei und ich komme auf das familien
so einfachen verhältnis haben eine gute
kindheit gehabt hat jetzt leider oder
gott sei dank nicht irgendwelche
geschichten da laufen sehr behütet aber
mir war irgendwie gleich auf dem
campingplatz groß geworden ist mir zu
klein ist mir zu eng und ich hatte oft
glück ich hatte eine referendarin an der
schule ist war die iris weber die damals
sagte geben ein jahr nach amerika gesagt
getan bin ja nach amerika das hat mir
einfach noch mal die welt anders gezeigt
an der high school hat jedes kind
gearbeitet ich hatte jeden tag zwei
stunden sport und geest kind
tellerwäscher tatsächlich hasen gemacht
dass selbige morgen am tag die weder
rasenmähen wenn alles weg ist ich habe
geschaut meine ersten 1000 dollar
verdient für mich war klar ich möchte
kein millionär ja ich möchte einen
porsche fahren ob das jetzt
erstrebenswerte nicht ist oder nicht für
mich war das so und dann will ich wieder
gekommen da sagte bis zur lehrer dein
bruder studiert es gibt nur taxi fahren
ich hatte drei nebenjobs und habe
während meiner lehre schon mehr geld
verdient als mit dem lehrgeld
eine alles was sie erzählen als kugel
das passt ja in diese zahl stimmt und
sie müssen sich mal auch anschauen was
heute ankommt was die öffentlichen
debatten sind die frauenquote das gender
sternchen und vor allem was ich für auch
korrektiv alter das bedingungslose
grundeinkommen das unterschlägt als eine
maßnahme zur befriedung sein soll wurde
er zum ende der sendung 1 1 denken
sondern können sie eine positive sache
dem wunsch der jungen einer guten uhr
greift weil eins abgewinnen ja natürlich
diese jugend will zum beispiel nicht
kämpfen was ich ganz toll finde nicht
die idee dass man seine werte
verteidigen soll ist in dieser
gesellschaft nicht mehr vorhanden das
finde ich ganz positiv das verhindert
ein zweiter stalingrad
ja ja ja das sehe ich positiv aber schon
sie es ist völlig egal wie ich es sehe
wir können doch nicht darauf
vorbeischauen das wirklich merck sein
generationen stadt geweckt stadt
generationenwechsel stattgefunden hat
einen campari zu viel
es ist nicht mehr so dass arbeit was
zählt max hat glaube ich diesen genialen
satz gesagt reichtum ist caro meiner
arbeit so ähnlich und darauf kommt es
nicht machen wir haben über 100 länder
lehrstühle in der bundesrepublik ich
glaube für hoch und tiefbau gibt es
einen universitäten weniger lehrstühle
dieser gesellschaft ist die zeit gereift